[Music]
the flutter of a butterfly can cause a
typhoon
somewhere in the world on the 20th of
april 2021 the president of chad was
assassinated in a clash with rebels a
week later three journalists were killed
in burkina faso two of them were spanish
suddenly all of the media are talking
about the sahala region the hardest hit
area in the world
it is a strip of land that separates the
sahara desert from the great african
savannah the sahel
is as violent as iraq but much much
poorer it suffered colonialism
desertification and is now becoming the
focus of islamic terrorism and these
particular terrorists could conquer some
of the most important uranium mines in
the world
in other words they could obtain uranium
with which to manufacture so-called
dirty bombs despite all this the united
states is withdrawing the few trips it
had in the area there are more and more
russian mercenaries in the region and
there is only one power with a clear
interest
in this region france but what does
france care about what is happening in
the sahel what does the butterfly effect
have to do with all of this
and why should we care about what's
happening in the middle of africa in
this video we're going to explain all
[Applause]
[Music]
today it is easy to announce the abuses
committed by the spanish or
the british empire but let's be honest
if there had been a predatory colonial
power it is undoubtedly the french
empire until the 1970s france had
colonized almost a third of the entire
african population
algeria mali chad all of these are among
the many former french colonies for more
than a century and a half france
exploited the natural resources of this
continent leaving broken societies in
its wake
next to them the spanish and british
conquerors would have looked like
care bears and now france continues to
do the same but in a different way
in the so-called franca afrique france
removes and puts in place the dictators
that suit its best and this brings us
back to the sahel but what exactly is
this a hail you may ask it is the strip
that separates the sahara desert from
the great african savannas an area where
it's practically impossible to grow
anything where there are frequent
droughts and where 8 out of 10
inhabitants live on around 1.90 cents a
day we have told you a thousand times
here on visualpolitik poverty is
disappearing in the world however
this hill is one of the few places where
it persists and there seems to be no
sign of improvement in fact
it's quite the opposite and don't think
we are talking about a small region
look at this map
[Music]
this hill is home to more than 300
million people spread over several
countries burkina faso
mali niger chad and many others to give
you an idea how big the region is the
distance from east to west
is basically the same as the distance
from seattle washington to panama well
this hill has always been poor but now
on top of all this misery there is
violence
thousands of people die every year at
the hands of terrorist groups both al
qaeda and the islamic state have
branches here and the presence is
increasingly important and all of this
explains news headlines like this one
france to deploy extra troops to fight
extremists in africa's sahel wall street
journal today
france has more than 5 000 troops
deployed in the sahel the un has been
conducting the minnesota operation for
eight years to stabilize the situation
in mali the european union has two
training missions and sends several
million euros in humanitarian aid every
year but to date none of this is helped
meanwhile both turkey and russia are
paying more and more attention to this
region so the question is what exactly
is france doing in this region is what's
happening in this
hill really that important today we're
gonna answer all of these questions but
first
let's look at some history
the evil triangle if there's a hail
we're a country in terms of population
it would be the fourth
largest country in the world and as you
can imagine this region is anything but
homogeneous
there are a lot of inequalities and
differences if we compare the western
and eastern parts so
in today's video we are going to focus
on five countries in the central and
western sahara we are talking about
burkina faso
chad mali mauritania and niger
these countries have three things in
common since 2014 they've been part of
an alliance known as the g5 sahel
all five were former french colonies and
are now failed dictatorships that is
dictatorships where the dictator does
not even have control of his entire
country these are areas dominated by
tribes and terrorist groups and if all
this already sounds bad there is an area
within the sahel that is even worse
the so-called triple frontier or what we
could call the triangle
of evil look at this map
[Music]
as you can see we are talking about this
area within the triple borders of
burkina faso
niger and mali historically this region
was called leptako gurma but we call it
the triangle of
evil in recent years it has become the
epicenter of jihadist violence add drug
human and arms trafficking and you have
the full picture all of which explains
news headlines like this one
france boosts spachane force to 5100
troops to further focus on mali
burkina faso niger tri-border area the
defense post
but why does france in particular have
such an interest in this region have you
been following visualpolitik for a while
you could probably guess the answer
for centuries france was the main
colonizing power in africa 60 years ago
france left the continent but let's be
honest they have never
really completely abandoned their
colonies for example you know that
france is one of the world's leading
nuclear powers not only do they have the
atomic bomb but they also rank second in
the list of countries with the most
nuclear power plants in the world to
give you an idea
70 of france's electricity comes from
its nuclear power plants
and where does france get the uranium to
power so many nuclear power plants by
simply from countries like gabon
and chat both former french colonies
and so far there's no problem it could
be a purely commercial relationship but
the reality is that france has been
putting in
and taking out dictators to guarantee
its uranium supply to give you an idea
france's influence in africa is
so great that even the currency used in
most of this a hill the cfa franc is
linked to the french treasury
[Music]
i can already tell you that in the
future this might change because west
african countries are considering
switching their own currency called the
eco but
until this happens even the banking
systems of the countries that depend on
the cfa franc depend
on paris and now i know what you're
thinking but wait a minute grant france
hasn't done anything that for example
the united states hasn't done right and
yes you are right
but as we say on this channel the devil
is in the details the biggest difference
between france and any other colonial
power is precision for example the
united kingdom colonised india and its
presence reached every corner of the
country i'm very sorry india as bad as
it was the british also took charge of
building railroads schools
and security in the cities france was
much more precise
what i mean by precise well take a look
at this map
what you are looking at is the map of
railroad tracks that exist in africa
today most of them were built in
colonial times as you can see the train
tracks located in the western sahel have
one thing in common they leave from the
coast and arrive in the place where the
natural resources are in other words
they only serve to make a quick trip
collect all the natural resources and
then return to the big cities this
explains why the south of sahel has
trains and the north
doesn't
[Music]
basically the french settlers were
concerned with controlling the mines
the rest was left completely unattended
all of this explains why mauritania
despite having been a french colony was
the last country in the world to abolish
slavery until
1981 it was perfectly legal to own
slaves in this country even today
fattening farms still exist that is
farms where women are fattened to meet
traditional
beauty standards which is crazy we don't
need farms for that in scotland we just
do it ourselves
[Music]
add to all this droughts and climate
change the sahara desert is expanding
year after year according to the u.n the
temperature in this region is rising 1.5
times faster than the rest of the world
so what's the conclusion apart from the
uranium and gold mines almost the entire
territory of the sahel is controlled by
tribes the tuareg for example are one of
these nomadic tribes that have been
fighting for years
to have their own state and this is just
one of the many ethnic groups that have
been fighting each other for years but
the question is
why is this starting to worry us right
now why is europe sending so many
soldiers to this region what exactly has
changed well we're going to take a look
at that
right now
[Music]
the libyan war there's another area in
which france is different from any other
power the way they were to war
they run away a lot i'm kidding when the
united states spends real fortunes
trying to rebuild the country's attacks
france is much more pragmatic
[Applause]
for example the war in iraq cost the
white house more than 700 billion
dollars
mostly in trying to rebuild the country
after the fall of saddam hussein
although whether or not they succeeded
it's kind of another matter but what
happened in the libyan war just the
opposite the libyan war cost the french
a little over one billion dollars and
how is it possible for war to be this
cheap very easily because the french
arrived overthrew gaddafi
secured the oil fields and left so
imagine the scene eh pierre we have
opened a real can of women's here
they're killing each other we even have
the islamic state sniffing about
let's see jean-paul are there terrorists
where's the oiliest
no well missionary let's go home and why
am i talking about the wars in libya now
remember at the beginning of this video
we talked about the butterfly effect in
this story there are also many dots that
are connected qadhafi had one of the
best armed forces in all of africa
guess where all those weapons ended up
in sight arms and men out of libya
fortify mali rebellion reuters
until that point mali may have had
guerillas but they were guerillas
with hardly any weapons suddenly all of
the conflicts in mali became a problem
for the whole world the tuareg are a
berber people of the sahara desert
they're spread across six countries and
one of them
is mali so let's check out yet another
map
[Music]
as you can see if we focus on
ethnicities the north south division is
very clear in mali the capital
bamako is in the south whereas half of
the northern part is inhabited by the
tuaregs the touaregs had tried to gain
independence several times and now
they had libyan weapons to defend their
cause but this is not all because in
addition to secessionism the war in mali
had another protagonist jihadism a
radicalized part of the insurgents
decided to act on their own
to impose sharia law throughout the
region we are talking for example about
ansar deen a tuareg islamic group that
was created in march of 2012. in
addition there are
other groups out there such as al-qaeda
and the islamic maghreb the movement for
oneness
and jihad in west africa as well as the
ominous sounding
those who sign in blood
in short these are the last type of
people that you want to have any weapons
at all by 2012 the situation was already
escalating at an incredible speed in a
matter of months they were already in
control of the entire north of the
country at least this was the name that
tuareg gave to their conquered
territories the malian government was on
the ropes who could save them surprise
surprise
[Music]
france joins fight against mali
islamists hollande says
france 24. on the 11th of january 2013
the malian government itself requested
military assistance from its former
colonial master and on the same day
fighter jets emblazoned with the french
flag were already flying
over the sahel the question is has
france managed to erase jihadist
terrorism from the area
and why should they even care about
jihadism in the sahel get ready because
we're going to look at that right now
[Music]
an impossible puzzle in 2013 the malian
government asked france for help since
then the french army
still has a presence anti-french
sentiment in mali is getting stronger
and stronger
in france there is more and more
opposition to this war and this is why
you'll ask so why is france still there
isn't france supposed to be not
interested in rebuilding the country's
attacks
point one do you remember what france's
main interest in the sahel has
historically been
exactly natural resources if islamist
forces were to gain control of strategic
deposits
france could be left without chad's oil
mallee's gold or nitrous uranium
it's true that none of these countries
is an essential exporter but
there is a problem as i just told you
nycha has two large uranium mines one in
our elite and the other in akuta for
decades this uranium has been going to
french nuclear power plants
now however many are afraid that this
uranium could end up in the hands of
jihadists so they could make nuclear
weapons don't worry no they couldn't
making atomic bombs requires almost an
unthinkable amount of technology for a
terrorist group however they could
manufacture something similar the
so-called
dirty bombs
that is bombs that contain uranium and
that when exploding can contaminate
everything around them there's been much
speculation about the risk that these
dirty bombs could pose but the truth is
that when in doubt it is better to
protect uranium mines which explains
new stories like this
[Applause]
france protects niger uranium mine bbc
however
this is not the real problem and this is
where we come back to the butterfly
effect
instability in a remote part of the
world could generate a very big problem
in france
[Music]
there's one thing i have not yet told
you in this video the sahel is a
demographic time bomb for example it is
estimated that the population of niger
could quadruple by 2050. so we have a
region that is getting poorer more
violent and has more and more people
and all of this means just one thing new
migrant caravans
and if you are a malian or a chadian
which european country would you pick to
move to i mean
it's easy right a country where you can
already speak the language and more
importantly where you are likely to meet
people from your community maybe even
like a second or third cousin
we are talking of course about france
according to figures from france's
national institute of statistics and
economic studies more than
46 of migrants living in france were
born on the african continent and this
data does not even cover a regular
migration add to this the terrorist
threat in france and you will understand
why they are so concerned about
controlling migration flows
so the question is what are they doing
to prevent this new caravan of refugees
on the one hand we have a whole series
of military missions first
in 2013 france launched operation serval
an intervention in mali endorsed by the
u.n security council it involved 3500
french troops
a year later zerval gave way to the
anti-terrorist organization barkain
5 100 french soldiers and 405 of other
nationalities
in 2020 the european union created a
task force called takuba all of these
operations have also benefited from the
invaluable health of the united states
but let's be honest france has never
allowed the white house to meddle too
much
from the beginning these were all
french-led operations don't forget that
for france the most important thing is
to maintain
influence in this area and the last
thing they want in this respect is
competitors so the question is
are these missions really working and
the answer is
france and the united states are making
west africa's security situation worse
foreign policy at this stage it seems
that a purely military solution will not
be enough other powers such as turkey
have already sent medicines and masks to
niger and chad to fight covert 19.
[Music]
thanks to this eight turkey is buying a
lot of good will and that explains why
france is changing its strategy from
ultra-pragmatic military interventions
they are moving to carrot and stick
stick
for the jihadists and carrot for loyal
governments take for example the great
green wall project this is a massive
project to create a very long strip of
forests and farms to prevent
desertification this project was started
in 2007
but had hardly any money and so in
conclusion it didn't work well since the
beginning of 2021 france has started to
put money in and truth be told
they have spared no expense
great green wall receives over 14
billion dollars to re-green the sahel
france world bank listed among donors
unccd
but now it's over to you do you think
this new french strategy will prevent a
new migrant caravan what do you think
would happen if france withdrew his
troops from one day to the next do you
know
any other example of how old colonial
policies continue to have an impact on
today's world and most importantly just
how racist was my french accent
you can leave your answers in the
comments below as always don't forget
that here on visualpolitik we have new
videos every week so subscribe to the
channel and hit the little bell down
there so you don't miss any of our
updates
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and i'll see you in the next
one and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there